Please join me in welcoming Justin Baldoni.
Okay,
thank you Courtney.
Oh,
it's so awkward when you read all that stuff about you don't want any,
are there?
Hi.
Hi everyone.
Can we just take a moment together to just breathe and just have,
I don't know how I'm going to moderate this panel and I'm a wreck.
I was sitting out there,
that's why we just watched it.
Oh,
and I just want to have just,
just,
yeah,
we just,
I just wanna have a quick moment of silence just for those who are dealing with
cystic fibrosis and other illnesses,
those who have lost their lives,
those who are fighting the fight right now.
I'm a mess.
I'm just take a moment with me and let's just breathe in the space.
Okay.
That was beautiful.
Thank you for that.
We're honoring everyone just like that.
It's so funny.
I came in,
I,
you know,
cause I've been doing press all day for the movie,
so I came in with a totally different energy and this whole room.
I see.
So sorry.
I was like racing to get here and I was like,
oh wait,
you just watched the movie?
So I just wanted to,
yeah,
just have that feeling.
That was deep.
Did you like it?
Oh,
thank God.
It was,
it was really good.
And congratulations on the movie.
Um,
hi everyone again.
My name is Daria like Daria Sunshine.
I'm trying to bring the sunshine back.
Um,
it was beautiful and you,
and I don't know if you,
how much you saw,
but it was amazing.
We were oohing and aahing and crying and laughing and they were just so many
emotions and it was really incredible.
Um,
so you know,
we all know you probably as Rafael from Jane the Virgin,
and so I just want to congratulate you on directing your first major feature
film.
And I just want you to kind of tell us here,
Justin,
kind of what that was like and,
and what is it about this film and this story in particular that made you want
to make that jump and come behind the scenes?
Oh,
uh,
that's a multiple part question.
I'll get into the,
the reasons we made the movie.
So,
uh,
believe it or not,
we have in one way or another,
Google the thank for all of it.
So I,
I gave up acting and this career that I thought I wanted when I was in,
you know,
about seven or eight years ago to start a documentary series that was paid for
by Youtube,
uh,
via soul pancake called my last days.
And,
uh,
and I basically traveled the country and I told the stories of incredible
individuals who were living with a terminal illness.
And my prayer was that by doing this show and by spending time with these
amazing people who were choosing love and hope and happiness in the face of
tremendous adversity,
that maybe we could all learn how to live and learn how to live from people who
were literally dying,
even though technically,
of course we all know there's a clock.
This was,
this was,
it's in your face.
And of course it ended up becoming one of the most watched documentary series
ever on Youtube.
And then we ended up selling that to CW and,
and season two of my last days,
I met a young woman named Claire Wineland who was a youtuber and Claire
Wineland,
um,
had cystic fibrosis.
And I told her story in the second season of my last days.
And her and I became very dear friends and she kind of became like a little
sister to me.
And,
uh,
and it was in a conversation with her when she told me that two people with CF
can't touch me because I had actually,
I had asked her afterwards,
I was like,
all right,
let's now that,
that what the cameras are not rolling.
Tell me about boys.
Like,
tell me some boy stories in the hospital,
like if you ever dated a CFR.
And she was like,
what?
No.
And that's how I learned that this was a real thing.
And I just knew that it was a film.
Um,
and I had also,
interestingly enough,
back to the youtube thing,
I had set up another movie based on another documentary that I had made on this
young boy named Zach Sylvia,
who had also,
um,
had terminal cancer and wrote a song called clouds,
right.
Which ended up going very viral.
And there was a time when I didn't know which movie was going to happen first,
but we develop this,
um,
with Claire and,
uh,
and injected a lot of her soul into the spirit because as you know,
I don't know if you knew who she was,
but she used her platform on youtube that Google gave her,
uh,
to have conversations that were uncomfortable about life and about death and
about happiness and not being defined by the,
the,
what the world puts on you and not being defined by her illness and having her
illness be a part of her story,
but not all of our story and making her life a beautiful piece of art,
which is something that I think we can all relate to,
which I really tried to infuse into the film.
And as to why I chose to go behind the camera,
I was always,
I felt meant to be behind the camera.
But as you know,
when you come to Hollywood,
they put you in the box that they want to put you in.
Um,
so,
uh,
I was putting the,
the acting box first and then did everything I can to use that platform to then
transition to tell the stories that I feel like I was put on earth to tell.
Thank you and bless you for that.
Uh,
I follow you on Instagram.
You're just a light a light.
And because of that,
I also followed Claire and I remember watching her stories and her videos and
sitting here watching this,
uh,
character reminded me a lot of Claire how she,
you know,
documented her time.
And so it's funny to hear you kind of say how,
you know,
helped us develop the movie,
which is beautiful.
And Claire is no longer with us.
Claire,
I'm going to try to not get too emotional,
but we lost Clara just before I finished my director's cut of the movie.
Yeah,
thank you.
So this was beautiful.
And I think that one of the most special and beautiful parts about this movie is
that we have an element of computer science and that's how we were able to
partner together.
And still,
his character is actually the one who codes the APP.
Yes,
that Rachel a Co created that we'll get to in a moment.
Um,
but yeah,
wanting to ask you like how did that come about it and bringing Google the CS
media.
Tell us more.
Um,
so partly through you and Courtney.
so,
uh,
we had through my company,
Wayfair created a show that we had been working on for quite a while called
project upgrade,
which was basically giving,
uh,
trying to make stem sexy essentially and cool for your young woman.
And so my good friends,
the Merrill twins,
we brought them on and we created the show with deray and Courtney.
And,
uh,
and,
and through that conversation I was having a chat with Courtney and I sent her
the script and,
um,
just for some thoughts of ways that we could all collaborate.
And she wrote me back and said,
hey,
I'm,
there is,
because originally when we,
when we had first written the script,
we hadn't made her,
um,
that she was of course obsessive compulsive,
but she,
she did everything on paper.
And so it was,
it was like in spreadsheets and it was on paper.
And,
and Courtney had the idea of like asking if I would be open to doing it as an
APP.
And I said that's hell yeah.
I said that's even better.
And it was fun because then we got to like adjust the character a little bit.
And that just goes to show you how important these initiatives are.
Right.
And your,
and what you guys were literally hired to do is to consult and to work with
people like me and say,
hey would you be open to this?
This is an initiative we want to get more young women and girls into stem.
Let's create a character that does it and not make it a big thing.
Make it like she just happens to do it right.
Cause that's how you change things.
You need to be able to see yourself on the damn screen if you can't see yourself
on the damn screen and then you don't know that it's really possible unless you
know you,
it's just in bedded in you that that's an option.
I can do that.
And I just said that's,
yeah.
So we just,
we changed it immediately and worked on it and got some even fun moments like
when she's coding and will says like,
wait,
you built an APP?
And then a little bit of that like,
Oh yeah,
I built it up kind of moment.
Um,
and then the next fun part was I was like,
let's really build an APP.
Let's not just say it,
but let's do it.
Because it's so important for me that we're marrying what we say,
right?
It's one thing to say,
we all know these companies and all these people that are like,
oh,
we'll do this and we'll do this.
And you see these advertising campaigns and you name it,
right?
But it's like who's doing it?
And I think that's how change really starts in our businesses.
We have to do it.
So we said,
let's really build an APP and make something that people can actually use that
have chronic illnesses.
And so we were connected with these amazing young women,
um,
who dove in and designed it and built it.
And now there's going to be an APP,
right?
Hey and it's just an that's so cool and hopefully it will be useful.
That's all right.
Rachel,
why don't you tell us a little bit more about that.
And I know you were able to build and design an APP that made it into a feature
film,
which is incredible.
You did that with your partner Lavanya saying,
just tell us a little bit about what that experience was like.
It was amazing.
Um,
so Google reached out to Lavanya and I,
um,
in October and asked us,
how would you feel about building an APP for a movie?
And we were like,
that would be amazing.
Um,
so basically we got to talk to Justin and we got to talk to Courtney and what we
determined was the design for the APP through that.
And then we built the,
what you see in the movie first,
and we're continuing to build the APP right now and it should be released by the
end of March,
which is really exciting.
Okay.
It's amazing.
And this is the Vanya Lavanya is here in spirit.
She is caught up in midterms right now at Harvard.
No big deal.
So,
uh,
so the high Lavanya if you're watching on the livestream,
hi everyone on livestream,
but let's just show a quick clip,
uh,
about,
the APP that shook though show was showcased in the movie.
What's
their real code?
That's my favorite.
Okay.
Awesome.
Yeah.
And I think we have some stills of the APP to correct.
Can I just say that?
I love that she gets frustrated by a bug.
Thank you for making it real.
Really.
Very cool.
So,
so tell us like,
what inspired you to want to get involved in,
in the film and in creating this APP with your friend?
Um,
so I was first exposed to computer science in sixth grade and middle school and
I,
uh,
was interested,
but I wasn't super interested because I didn't really feel like it was pertinent
to my life that much.
I was just coding something where like bunnies running around on a hill.
It was very silly.
And then when I was in eighth grade,
I discovered a website called Code Academy where you can teach yourself how to
code through tutorials.
So I decided to do the build a website tutorial.
And,
um,
basically it was blown away by the possibility of being able to create something
that could impact a lot of people instantly.
Um,
so I continued teaching myself how to code throughout high school and in terms
of this app,
um,
I think that I actually got to talk to somebody with cystic fibrosis through
this process and hear about their experience and all the medications that they
have to take.
And,
um,
setting reminders is one thing,
but I also think it's useful to have something that actually reflects your own
experience,
whether that's a film or whether that's an app where it's actually catered to
things that you need and they're like really specific details that,
um,
coordinate with your life really well.
Yeah.
Amazing.
And I'm just curious here in the audience,
how many of you are interested in technology or computer science?
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
Quite a few people.
How many of you are into tech and computer science are either you're kind of
interested in it,
but you feel like you don't belong or you haven't quite made that leap yet?
There's some hesitancy.
Okay.
Well,
hopefully you feel inspired to do it right.
No matter your circumstance,
you can do it right.
Like Courtney was alluding earlier.
I mean,
if you can see it,
you can be it.
And like when I was growing up,
I was really good at math and science.
I was really a tech savvy,
but I was never exposed to anyone who looked like me doing it.
And I shied away from it.
And now I'm very fortunate to be able to advocate for it,
right.
For people who want to do it.
And so,
you know,
I think we're all appear today to just encourage you all to continue that.
So thank you,
Rachel for being a pioneer in the space and for creating the APP.
That was amazing.
I mean,
I was floored just seeing that in a major film.
So congrats to you and,
uh,
Justin,
thank you for highlighting it.
And,
I mean,
you used your platform all the time to,
to,
you know,
showcase these social issues.
And we've seen it with man enough and my last days and project upgrade,
which you talked about,
uh,
with your partner far who'd May Bowtie and you worked with Courtney on that and,
and that's a youtube series.
Um,
that's,
you know,
uh,
up on the platform for free that everyone can watch and it stars the Merrill
twins and they're working with a diverse team of female engineers to build a
digital interactive mirror.
Um,
and so you're just phenomenal.
And I want to know ultimately what motivates you,
uh,
to then encourage women to pursue stem and like what,
what motivates you to get behind that cost so deeply?
I mean,
it all,
it all stems back from me to faith.
Um,
I think,
uh,
you know,
I was raised in the Bahai faith and I mean,
it all comes to me.
To me it just all comes back down to the female education and the impact.
I mean,
it literally in my faith it says if you have two children,
a boy and a girl,
but you can only afford to educate when you educate the girl.
And uh,
and because that's how you change the world.
So I mean,
it's not like I grew up thinking stem.
I got to get young women and girls in the stem.
It's when issues are presented to me and my privilege allows me to then amplify
a cause or an issue that I feel is important.
And it's tricky because there's so many things that need amplification.
Um,
and I,
you can't take everything on,
but you know,
piece by piece and,
uh,
this was,
I have a guy have a young daughter and you know,
I would be so happy and thrilled to see her end up like you and uh,
yeah.
So I don't know,
I guess it,
it all stems down to faith and why are you here?
What are you doing with your time?
And Yeah.
Amazing.
Thank you.
Speaking of women in stem,
we have the phenomenal Kim Swindon over here on the end.
Um,
and you actually were featured in project upgrade and you worked really closely
with,
you know,
other amazing women working in tech fields all around.
Um,
so just talk to us a little bit more about that experience and kind of explained
a little bit about your role here at Google.
Slash.
Youtube.
Yeah.
So,
um,
yeah,
I was really grateful to be able to contribute to a project upgrade.
It was an awesome project.
Um,
a couple of us were sort of industry mentors for the Merrill twins and the group
of college students that they were working with to build this app,
um,
and the filmmakers and,
you know,
fair.
Um,
and uh,
yeah,
so I work on Youtube.
Um,
as Courtney mentioned,
whenever you hit that big red subscribe button,
which was featured in the movie,
um,
some of my code runs somewhere in a data center.
Um,
and uh,
yeah,
I came to computer science kind of security actually.
I started out in entertainment.
I was an actor in Hollywood.
Um,
I,
I was not placed there.
I was trying very hard to get there.
Um,
but I actually realized that I,
I'm,
I've always been really drawn to math and science and,
uh,
this notion that you get to build something and to have people use something you
built and sort of make an impact in their life with that over and over and over
again is just a totally different kind of satisfaction to helping people feel
something or discover something.
So I still love to do both.
Um,
but that was sort of my trajectory to get to computer science.
And I think it's been really a blessing to be at Google where we have so many
effort to try to encourage girls and young women and underrepresented boys to be
interested in computer science.
Because I empathize with the difference,
the gap between how it's portrayed in the media and how it is in real life
because I was sort of exposed to both sides.
So
I love that.
And I want you to speak more about that because when I first met you,
I was so inspired by you because we share an acting background and I was like,
wow,
I'm so glad that she does both,
right?
That they're not mutually exclusive,
exclusive.
And that's something that really try to preach it.
Google is right.
You can do both.
And just can you talk a little bit more about that and,
and,
and what,
what made you say no,
I'm going to do both.
I don't have to split it.
I think a lot of people are right.
They have,
you know,
the left side of the rent.
They also have the right side and they're creative and they want and they want
to find those intersections.
How do you go about that?
And so to be clear,
I get all the time,
uh,
oh,
you're both right brain and left brain.
How weird.
Why are those split?
I don't know why that's um,
I've also gotten,
oh,
you're too pretty to be a software engineer,
which is a weird combo salt.
Um,
that's awesome.
Yes.
Backhanded compliment,
complex all them.
Um,
so,
so yes,
it is.
It is absolutely possible to do both.
And to be really clear,
I was terrified.
Um,
seriously.
And I think it's important to like make that be known,
right?
This,
it's not,
it's not an easy field,
but it's also not,
it's hilarious to say this,
but it's also not rocket science.
When my joke with my friends that like space x,
they crack up with that.
Um,
so like I say that because I think a lot of,
a lot of,
not just girls,
but young people sort of try out tech and computer science and science and they
find it hard.
And the first thing you think is,
I must just not be good at this.
Right.
And unless you have those people,
and in my case,
it was my ex boyfriend who was a software engineer,
when I started thinking about what else could I do in my life besides acting,
could I actually do this for real?
I'm way too old to get into computer science.
I was in my thirties when I decided to go back to school.
Um,
it takes that one person being like,
no,
you got this.
This is not,
this is not as hard as you think.
Like,
just push through,
try to understand it,
get the help you need,
get the support.
Um,
it's totally doable.
But I think we get so many of those messages that,
that this is intimidating and it's computers or hard and confusing.
And,
and we kind of take that in and assume that that's the limiting factor.
Yeah.
So thank you.
And what about you Rachel?
What are some of this,
you know,
miscommunications misconcepts that you've heard about stem and you know,
did you ever fair or did you have a fear to,
to pursue it?
And what are some things that you had to push against?
I was never really afraid to code,
are afraid to do math and science.
Um,
I feel like I was raised in an environment where that was like,
there was no question as to whether that was something I could do.
It was,
I could do it if I wanted.
However,
I did naturally gravitate towards reading and storytelling,
um,
when I was little.
So for me,
um,
coding is not something that I'm naturally good at.
I work really hard at it,
but I also think that nobody's really naturally good at it and everybody has to
work really hard at it.
So I think knowing that like you do have to,
um,
keep going,
even if it's difficult and you might be confused for a while,
but then you'll figure it out I think is really important.
It's important in life tail.
Um,
I also think there's a huge misconception that you have to be good at math to be
good at coding.
Um,
I like math,
I don't love it.
Um,
but I don't really use that much math and coding.
I think coding is really logical and it's based off of principles like loops and
recursion and um,
yeah,
yeah.
Thank you.
I mean it's so true.
We all get these misconceptions about tech and computer science,
right?
Like,
you know,
Courtney and I have worked on shows like the fosters in Silicon Valley and miles
from tomorrow land in East Los High.
And you know,
Kim has been an amazing engineer who actually,
you know,
uh,
helps us write the codes for a lot of those shows.
Right?
And now we have Rachel and Justin and we are getting all these partners to
really change the culture and perception around tech so that once people do come
to places like Google,
we can retain them once they get here.
Right?
Is Not a pipeline issue.
The pipeline is there,
but what are the messages that we are,
uh,
you know,
sharing with,
with the world.
And that's why I think media is just so important,
right?
Because right now if we were to look at TV,
uh,
and I think we're making some progress,
but you know,
we think it's only for,
you know,
cis straight white men or Asian men with glasses and acne and no personality and
no friends.
And they sit in closets and eat doughnuts all day and type on their computer.
And it's like,
no,
the computer sciences aren't generic,
can be anyone,
right?
It can be everyone and we need to think more inclusively.
And so I just commend you both,
uh,
have for kind of going the distance and pushing its obstacles and for you,
you know,
just to be such an incredible ally in the space.
It means so much and I think that you are encouraging,
you know,
the next generation,
to to think differently and to be man enough and you know,
to stand up for what's right.
So I just,
you don't want to thank all of you for that.
And I'm just wondering what advice,
what advice would you give,
um,
you know,
looking back on your,
on your journeys and your experiences,
what advice would you give to those,
uh,
here?
Maybe some young women,
uh,
or just anyone who's underrepresented in the space,
those on live stream,
you know,
what,
what would you tell them Rachel,
start with you.
Um,
I would tell them that you don't need to feel like it's something that is not
for you because it is for you,
but it's how you apply it to your life in terms of it being,
um,
related to you.
Um,
for example,
like I developed this app related specifically to cystic fibrosis and other
illnesses,
but like the fun part of it was not the coding,
the fun part of it was the impact in the fun and what was going to be created at
the end.
Um,
for me coding is about the process.
It's not about the processes if it's about what's being created,
but the process is needed in order to create something.
It's Kinda like if you're directing a film,
you will have to know about cinematography,
but the camera is not the thing.
The film is the thing that you're watching and coding is similar in that way.
Um,
I would also say that there are other girls who do it.
They might not be around you.
There are a lot of programs that connect girls who are interested in coding like
NC wit,
um,
girl up.
Uh,
there's a camp called
why side,
which has applications out right now Kode with Klossy.
Um,
they are just a lot of opportunities for girls to get involved in stem.
Amazing.
Thank you.
What about you Kim?
What would you add?
I actually taught at why.
So I,
last year I went to [inaudible],
which one?
In Malawi.
Oh,
okay.
I taught at the one in Namibia.
So for those who don't know why I say is a partnership between the United States
at the US State Department and an organization called girl up,
which is a campaign of the United Nations Foundation and it brings a girls from
different countries together to learn stem,
not in the u s so when I attended it was in Malawi and there were 20 girls from
the u s and 80 girls from six different African countries.
It was amazing.
Um,
yeah.
Yeah,
no,
it was teaching.
There was phenomenal.
I mean the range was,
some girls had already learned some code and some girls had never touched a
mouse and they were all helping each other to learn.
It was like one of the most inspiring,
awesome experiences.
And by the end of it,
they all had an APP that they'd built.
Wow.
So like again,
not rocket science,
right?
Like you get,
you get a group of people together and inspire them and like it's,
it's,
it's just trying it out,
see what works.
Yeah.
Um,
the only thing I would add would be,
um,
don't be afraid to break things.
I know that sounds kind of interesting.
Um,
be a little afraid if it's youtube.
but,
but even that,
like,
I,
I mean,
honestly that's,
it's something I,
I kind of had to learn the hard way and I was never really taught to tinker as a
kid and in my,
as my education was very much about like,
memorize the right answer and spit it out.
So I kind of never got that experience of like see what works and try it.
And if it breaks,
oops,
well at least I learned something.
It is such an invaluable thing to be willing to do in engineering because you
learn so much about something by breaking it.
Um,
so,
so it's just part of the process.
If you break it,
it's not that big a deal unless it's youtube.
Yeah.
But what about you,
Justin?
Like good.
Anything that you would share?
Um,
just in terms of those who might want to pursue stem or coding or anything.
Yeah,
when I graduated from Harvard with a degree in rocket science,
by the way,
I love that.
My,
one of my favorite parts of your stories when you're like,
when I joke with my friends at space x,
because I just kind of was like imagining you talking about things with your
friends at space x and me on the outside.
Just having no clue what you're talking about.
Trying to follow the conversation often.
Probably not talking about anything that,
that,
that's that high level to be honest.
Well,
in my mind you are,
I'll take it.
Um,
uh,
I was so in,
I was so entrenched in their questions.
What,
what was my question again?
Like I was like with them and I was thinking about how do I translate that into
talking to my daughter about,
yeah.
What would you tell Maya?
I would,
I would connect her with them and the one I knew.
I do have a question for you though.
What do you want people to take away from,
from your film?
I mean,
watching that,
I was just like,
wow,
I need to live more.
I need to get out of my phone,
I need to be in the moment.
I need to go home and cuddle with my boob,
Aaron and,
and,
and just live and dive more into art.
I love just how much,
you know,
how much art was in that and just how much living they did.
And it,
even though,
you know,
they have a terminal disease and it was beautiful and I just want to know what,
what do you want us to take away from that?
Yeah,
that,
sorry,
say more.
Look,
I think when you make anything,
you build anything,
you hope that it has impact and you always want to design or build or create
something with an intention.
Right?
And um,
for me the intention was as simple as if people leave this film and feel an urge
to call someone they love and just tell them they love them,
then I will have succeeded.
Or if maybe they can reexamine their relationship and realize that,
wow,
it's not all about physical touch.
There's more to it.
You know,
we live in this shiny,
glossy on demand society where we constantly like project out to the world the
way that we want to be seen instead of really who we are.
We swipe for love.
We,
we,
if it's not working immediately,
there's so many different options and we can just choose.
And I think that I just wanted to create a grounded love story that just kind of
reminded us that there's so much more an appreciation for life because I think,
you know,
if you don't have a chronic illness,
okay,
everybody suffers.
Everybody has things that are uncomfortable,
you know,
knee injuries for me and muscles things.
And there's always something that's life,
right?
But I think that in general,
what so many of us take for granted,
others are fighting for and it isn't like,
Oh,
poor them at all.
Because from my experience,
they're the ones that teach the rest of us how to live and be joyful.
And,
uh,
and so,
yeah,
I think it's just perspective.
Yes.
If there's a word,
it would be perspective.
And,
and I hope that it does that.
Please tell all your friends,
uh,
cause movies like this need support,
especially on opening weekend or the studios won't trust the people like me to
make them anymore.
Um,
so yeah.
What do you think?
Did Justin succeed Y'all?
Yeah,
so good.
So good.
Well,
we have a few minutes.
I do want to open up the audience right now for questions.
Uh,
take a minute.
Courtney here has a mic that she's going to throw at you.
It won't hurt the braveness.
Who's going to ask the question?
If anyone has a question for our panel?
Wait,
that's a literal Mike.
You can throw.
Yeah,
we have one right over here was saying you can drop the mic.
That's called the dad joke.
Everybody.
Okay,
I'm going to stand up.
Okay.
Hi,
I'm Kavita.
Um,
and I guess I have a question for all of the panel,
but I guess,
um,
Justin's specifically,
when you were making this film and he really had to think about the difficult
discussions within it,
um,
what struggles and what hurdles did you have to go through in order to make sure
that this movie wasn't patronizing?
It wasn't about Oh poor them.
It was empowering and its message was both effectual and impactful.
Yes.
Is it really?
It's a,
it's a really fine line and a tricky balance in one that I thought I was failing
out the entire movie.
Um,
you know,
again,
because it was because my friend inspired me to make it
her soul.
Claire's soul I feel is a huge part of this film and her whole purpose when she
was alive was to redefine what illness looked like.
So for me,
this was not a movie about sick kids and that's kind of unfortunately the way
the world projects their view of it.
This is a movie about regular teenagers who just happened to be sick and I think
that is the,
the most important like perspective of the film is that like this,
there's no romanticizing of an illness here.
This is just who they are.
That's right.
And it's as natural.
It's is why the first 10 minutes is just seeing them in their environment so
that you never have to go back and see it again.
And that was another thing,
like I wanted to show it up top and then never reference it again.
And you just know then that that's part of their life.
So even if you move on,
you know that she's got to do her treatments,
she's got to do that thing because no one wants to see that the whole time.
And in terms of the difficult conversations,
I have found that the people that I'm the closest to in my life,
I've had very difficult conversations with.
And I've also noticed how afraid our culture is of having difficult
conversations.
So I intentionally designed this film to be uncomfortable and it's certain areas
to hopefully inspire people to get comfortable having difficult conversations.
And if you notice the scene in the movie where they connect the most starts in
the worst way,
which is the,
the confession of the death of her sister and how it happened and the guilt that
she feels with it.
And if you think about like the,
the line that the scene takes,
it was very intentional that it started off that way and that it ends in the
most romantic,
intimate way.
You could ever have it end because those two things are not mutually exclusive.
But yet I think as a culture we say that they are.
Yeah.
And it was,
it was honestly,
it was hard for the studio.
It was hard.
I mean,
this,
you got to remember this studio,
like they are ballsy to let me go make this movie and to have like this
conversation in the romance scene and I had to explain why.
And that's why it's so deep.
That's why it's like you watch it and,
and,
and there's no sex scene in that movie,
but it's far more intimate than if there were.
That's right.
And that scene and that scene starts with the death of her sister.
And then it lightens up and then they connect and lighten this up.
And then I get closer.
And that's life.
And that's just what I've noticed.
And that's what I've learned from a lot of people that are in this situation.
My wife and I,
the closest,
some of the closest times we've ever had have started with pain.
And there's just not things that you see in these movies.
And I just wanted to make something that's like real and like,
no,
it's like we're like this.
It's okay.
You can just,
because your conference,
like on a date,
if the conversation it gets heavy,
your deeper,
darker,
depressing,
does it mean that date is bad or the person's not right for you?
Keep going.
What's on the other side of that uncomfortability?
Right.
And we so often like we're so quick to write things off and I don't know,
I just want us to like fight for things a little bit.
So anyways,
yeah,
great question.
Thank you.
Someone was in the back.
I saw him.
There she is.
You can just throw it,
just throw it.
Go for it.
I got to get one.
I need one of those.
Can you hear me?
Hi everyone.
My name's Joey.
I'm a computer science and theater double major at Middlebury College.
My question is for Kim.
Um,
yes.
So you said that you were in the film industry for a long time.
My question is twofold.
How did you transition from the entertainment industry to the tech industry and
how did you find an intersect intersectionality between them?
Because it's something that I'm struggling to do,
but I want to do in the future once I graduate.
Awesome.
I love that.
Um,
I will,
I'll give you two answers.
So,
um,
in terms of transitioning to,
to be,
to be fair because it's more dramatic if I'm like I had no math background,
I actually was a huge math person growing up,
so I did have a lot of exposure to it,
to math and science.
Um,
I didn't major in it in college.
I did take a couple computer science classes.
Um,
so 10 years later when I decided to get into the field,
um,
I knew I probably needed to get a master's degree or at least a second bachelors
to convince people to hire me cause just a theater studies degree might not cut
it.
Um,
and uh,
to be totally honest,
I convinced UCLA let me in.
And,
and by that I mean I got a ton of nos and being an actress in Hollywood,
I said,
forget that I'm doing it anyway.
Um,
so I followed up with the vice chair and said,
take a meeting with me.
And I sat down with him and I showed him my transcript from Undergrad and I
said,
you tell me what I needed to be to be competitive and I'll do it.
Um,
and so he basically said,
okay,
ace your math,
juries take these classes,
audit them,
ace them,
proof to us that you can handle the material and we'll go from there.
And what it took was basically just the,
you know,
help me make this happen,
but I'm going to make this happen.
So I audited classes for a year and then I got accepted into the master's degree
and that was a two year program and then Google hired me out of the gate,
which is awesome.
Um,
and thank God.
so then in terms of intersectionality,
I will tell you one of my,
sorry,
that was a misuse of that term in terms of the,
forgive me terms of the intersection of computer science and theater.
Um,
uh,
one,
one anecdote that made me feel really at home at Google very fast was a
orientation.
You go up to mountain view and you do a week of sort of preparing on classes on
the infrastructure.
And the lesson they had us do was I kid you not indexing the complete works of
Shakespeare.
And I was like,
I'm home.
Um,
and in terms of how I've tried to like carry that forwards,
um,
part of it was working on youtube to be totally honest cause that was like a
neat way to combine.
Um,
and what I'm doing right now,
like getting to,
to be on stage and use my performance skills to try to encourage other people to
get interested in science and,
and show them that can be fun is actually one of the ways that I've gotten to,
to do both.
And I've worked with the CSN media team for awhile and I got to be on a PBS kids
show for example,
or there was a,
the La Olympics Promo.
They were like,
Hey,
we need a female software engineer on camera.
Do you know of anyone?
And they're like,
actually we have one at Ge as a sag card and an agent.
So,
um,
awesome.
Um,
so there are definitely ways and I'm still looking for all the new ways.
I would be delighted if you went out and found the thing that that hit that
sweet spot for you and I'm sure it exists.
Yeah.
And keep using your influence right.
To to keep spreading the knowledge and go to production studios and talk to them
about what you want to see on TV or like Courtney and I also have a web series
called God complex and our executive producers in the house,
Claire Brown in the back.
And you know,
that's something that we,
that we did and we got engineers like Kim to advise on it and make the coating
like authentic and accurate and I also got to act in it.
Right.
So it's like really cool to kind of see those worlds intersect.
So keep,
keep creating,
right.
If it doesn't exist,
create it and like find your own lane and do what makes you happy.
You don't have to choose.
Thank you for being here.
I want to be like you when I grow up.
You won't be like you.
What are you double major in?
Computer Science and theater?
Yes.
You have a question right here.
Okay.
Um,
hi,
I'm Danny.
Um,
I'm a junior in high school and I'm not sure.
I think other other people in
cool.
Any other high schoolers,
don't leave her alone.
Leave her hanging.
All right.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
and I'm sure we're all thinking about colleges and I'm very interested in a wide
range of topics and it's,
it's hard to kind of distinguish what you want to do as 16 year old and it's
kind of hard to make that decision,
especially what topic you want to go into.
Do you think it's more important to focus on your community that you're going
into or the,
the value of the education system that is going to,
what do you saying Madam Harvard,
I would say,
so I went to the,
I'm a freshmen,
I went into this year saying I want to possibly major in either computer
science,
sociology or gender studies because those are the three things I'm interested
in.
Um,
and right now I feel like I want to eat,
either create my own major,
which specifically focuses on the impact of technology and media on society,
or I'm going to be a gender studies or sociology major with the computer science
secondary.
So I'm taking two computer science classes right now and I took a computer
science class last semester.
But I think you don't have to choose between things you're interested in.
There is a way to work everything together.
It just might not be the most traditional route.
Um,
but I think there's a lot of power in that as well because I think when you're
really specific and intentional,
you're going to a get the most out of it and then be,
um,
that's where the magic happens and that's where special things will happen.
And let me throw in that you're not going to get trapped by your major.
Right.
Cause same thing for theater studies major.
I'm now a software engineer.
Like,
so you get to change your mind.
And I think it's really common for people with multiple types of careers now.
It's so true.
When I first went to Dartmouth,
I was a biochemistry major and I wanted to be an obstetrician and deliver babies
and then I would go,
you know,
go to the Nicu and I'd cry every time.
I was like,
you are not Meredith grey abort mission.
And I switched my major from biochemistry to sociology and theater and I work at
Google.
It doesn't matter.
Do what makes you happy and then everything comes naturally and you can find
ways to work your passion and with your studies and your degree.
But no one's like,
what did you major?
And no one really cares.
Just do what makes you happy.
I don't care cause I didn't even graduate college.
There you go.
Don't take that route.
It's so much harder.
But he makes feature films.
Okay.
Any other questions?
Two more.
Yeah,
have one right here and then one right here.
All right.
Hello?
Um,
my name is Maya.
I'm also in high school.
I'm a here.
Um,
anyways,
so I'm taking comp side this year.
Come say hey,
I really like it.
Uh,
anyways,
what is that?
For those who might not know.
It's,
it's an AP computer science class.
It's one of two that's offered I think generally.
But there's,
there's a really competitive stigma with computer science.
Like everyone I know who codes is also very competitive and coding and um,
there's kind of a push to get straight A's and to do what you're good at so that
you can get straight A's.
Um,
and so how do you suggest kind of reverting from that stigma?
Because I like computer science but I'm not fantastic at it yet.
I'm not saying I'm not going to be,
I'm just saying I'm not fantastic at it yet.
But how,
how,
like how do you suggest pursuing something that you enjoy and being able to
reject that idea that you always have to do something that you're good at?
That's a great question.
That is,
you just put it really well yourself.
You just,
you have to reject the idea that you have to be good at it right now to do it.
Like cutting.
Like I said,
coding does not come naturally to me.
I'm definitely not the best in my computer science classes.
I'm definitely not getting straight A's,
I can assure you of that.
But I am trying really hard and I am getting better.
So I think you do have to trust in the process a little bit and know that you're
not going to be perfect and it's going to feel kind of hard and you're going to
be kind of mad at yourself during the process,
but you will get better.
And also,
um,
I think straight days aren't everything and they also don't prove what you've
made.
And I think something that's been really helpful for me is knowing that like I
can create things that don't have to do with grades that have to do with coding
because um,
that's when I feel most empowered is when I'm creating something that will
actually have an impact.
Okay.
I,
I've discovered the hard way.
You don't get an a at your job.
I'm like,
I seriously went out of Grad school being like,
all right,
how do I get nay?
And I almost literally had my first one on one with my manager where I was like,
okay,
what's the assignment?
And she's like,
no,
this is the problem.
You need to go figure it out.
We don't have the answer yet.
And I was like,
oh,
this is a different ball game.
So like getting an a in school,
you're sort of train that that is the goal.
But like in actual engineering doing side projects,
doing things that inspire you,
like getting your hands dirty,
that's so much more valuable in the long run.
So
great.
Good question right here.
Who has the mic?
Yeah,
good catches.
Um,
I'm Delilah.
I'm,
I'm a sophomore in high school and my question is more geared towards Justin and
like the whole like film making process.
And um,
I love all of the talk about intersectionality and how like one thing just
doesn't define you.
It's like so many things that are just meshed together and I mean they're
separate still,
but,
and was wondering,
I know that in trying to bring representation to,
um,
different groups,
it's kind of hard and like mainstream media to,
um,
to make something and just have it like,
be like an undertone.
Um,
and I was wondering if you got,
well if you got pushed back and like how you deal,
you dealt with that.
Um,
is there a specific pushback that you're asking about?
Not really.
I think it's just like general more open for you.
I think,
you know,
look,
we are,
we are living again,
I go back to the Times that we're living in,
right?
And you're living at a time when there's keyboard courage and the everybody has
an opinion and I come from the belief where there is an,
there you cannot make everybody happy.
And there,
there are people that don't want to be made happy and there are opinions that
aren't just the existing for the sake of opinions and,
and uh,
and there's always going to be pushed back about anything and everything.
I mean,
the perfect example is
like how could one of Claire's videos ever get a dislike?
But there is,
there's a hundred people out there that click that dislike button.
You know,
I'm,
I'll never forget Zach's mom when I made the documentary about Zach Sobeck who
died right before the documentary came out.
Or right after the doc American,
like within a day.
And like there was negative comments and,
and had,
and it just made me realize that there was nothing that anybody can make that
someone will have only positive opinions about.
And again,
then you look at film critics,
what is critic,
right?
It's not like there's a job for film supporters or you know,
it's just they're critiquing,
right?
So it's just the culture we live in and also everything is so instant that it's
like,
well,
I can just get my thoughts and opinions out into the world without thinking
about them now and just ruin somebody's day and then go on with mine.
Um,
so there,
there was absolutely,
there was pushback in the CF community by a couple people,
right?
And again,
it's up to me then to go and say,
well,
why is there push back?
And what I have to remember is like,
this is life and death for a lot of people.
That's it.
Right?
And so representing,
there's never been a film about CF before.
So the CF community needs to own it because it really,
it was made inspired by them and for them.
But I won't be able to please everybody.
But at the same time,
I have to remember,
and you know,
my friend gray here in the studio and my publicist and my assistant,
like I know I am a people pleaser.
I want to please everybody all the time.
And my mom always told me,
you'll never please everybody all the time.
Um,
you just need to worry having me be pleased that I was like,
okay,
you're taking it too far with the Jewish guilt mom.
Uh,
but,
but really so,
so yeah,
we strive for representation.
You know,
you,
you know,
and you,
you,
you try to be inclusive and come up with these ideas and create a film that
isn't just over the top,
you know,
like even down to,
I struggled for awhile because I just wanted to have diversity and be inclusive
in the way that I cast the movie.
And I found myself in certain times like,
like,
do I just find like,
you know,
cause I didn't,
you don't have the options to just cast whoever you want and then like,
you know,
you're not alone.
There's times that you can't go.
It's not PC to say like,
I would like to bring in only African American people for this role because then
you're thinking,
well crap,
I'm not thinking about the Asian community or the Middle Eastern community.
You're,
and then you realize like,
oh my God,
now I'm now I'm discriminated against.
And it's like,
oh shit.
And if you go down that rabbit hole,
it'll,
it will actually prevent you from doing anything.
And that's what I had to learn was,
was like,
I'm,
I know I'm going to disappoint somebody.
Um,
but I tried and we took baby steps and you know,
um,
yeah,
that's kind of like the,
how I approached the whole thing of that.
So we're at a time,
that's a great note to end on.
Just keep trying your hand.
I feel bad.
Oh,
you have a question?
No,
it's fine.
It was like a quarter raise real quick.
One last one.
Go for it real quick.
Okay.
Um,
my name is Sophia.
I'm a senior in high school.
Um,
and my question was one of the most interesting parts of the film for me,
it was the conversation that was had about like how to pay for the healthcare
and what you do,
um,
when you're over 18 and it's not covered.
So I was wondering,
um,
like what was for adjusting,
what was your intention in putting that in the film and what,
yeah,
thank you guys.
I'm so happy you actually noticed that.
Uh,
because nobody's seen the movie yet.
I don't know what people are going to respond to where,
like with what things are going to be put in there.
So originally Po had a whole backstory that I wasn't able to include in the film
because I wanted,
first of all,
I wanted I,
and again,
skating on this line and like on the razor's edge.
Like I wanted there to be a character that was a representation for an entire
class of people that are currently struggling with the medical system in
America.
And so,
um,
without getting too deep into politics,
I wanted to be a dreamer because we wrote the movie at a time when dreamers were
being attacked and um,
and I wanted people to be able to empathize with somebody that was a dreamer.
Now it's very hard to do that when you have a secondary character who's also a
marginalized group on a couple of different sides.
And then he's literally like,
he's just checking every box.
And I was like,
I can't just like,
that doesn't work,
right?
Just becomes too much.
And it's my desperate attempt to try to like make like make this film more than
just it.
Look,
it's already doing a lot,
but it's like how I always go like how can I do more?
Right.
And then you realize like,
I can't do more cause then I'm just going to push people and then it's just
going to be like,
it's going to be a whole group of people that they just think I'm pushing like a
liberal agenda and I'm not.
And it just,
the whole thing.
So Po was originally a dreamer and his mom had a,
his mom had brought him here for medical care,
um,
because it was better than where he was from.
And then she was deported.
That was the backstory that was cut.
And there was a scene that's in the deleted scenes of the movie.
When it comes out on Itunes,
you'll be able to watch it between,
uh,
that takes place in a chapel between Cole Sprouse is character will and Po.
Um,
that gets into a little bit more of the fact that his mom is no longer here and
he's got to pay for like his medical care himself and then will was rich.
So he made a joke about like,
well,
maybe I can help you.
Um,
and it was just a way of saying,
okay,
there's more to this character and there's,
there's consequences to being a sick in the current medical,
um,
world that,
that we're not really paying attention to.
So that's why I put it in there.
And then we did little things like he had a different oxygen tank.
Then the other two,
you might not notice it.
You might notice it.
That was important to me.
He had an older iPhone,
right?
Like little things that you may notice or may not with that.
Those were the things that were important to me because what nobody knows is the
oxygen tanks that will and stellar caring or $15,000 right?
And you can't get those if you don't have insurance.
And this could,
you know,
he's being paid for by the state and that's why it's a real thing.
And he does guilt and he doesn't want people to pay for him.
And it's a,
you know,
and those were all the things that they have to deal with on a daily basis and
that millions of Americans have to deal with that we never talk about.
So it was a,
it was an attempt.
So it makes me really happy that you noticed it cause I did.
Unfortunately I have to cut a lot of that storyline to make room for things.
Okay.
So everyone go see the movie 15 please.
Friday,
bring your friends,
tell people about it.
This is so important.
I can't stress it enough.
This type of film with this much diversity and inclusion and acceptance and love
and respect.
It's epic and we don't get it enough.
So let's give our panel one more round of applause.
Thank you all so much.
Cam,
Rachel,
Justin,
thanks to Courtney,
our production team,
all of our volunteers,
all of you for showing up and staying late.
I know you will have homework.
Go home,
do your homework,
get ready for work tomorrow we're going to take a quick photo and if you will,
could kindly pick up your trash and find your way out to the lobby.
I'm sure some of us will stick around to answer some more questions.